長にメンメンの英語を聞いて、英語で話すように言えば英語ができるように。
国とね、そうがあったのよ。国と私と英語で話そうって決めてね、スウェーデンに行った時に。
それで、いつも英語で話してる。
そうだ、この前どこで習ったって言ったでしょ、英語。
私の英語で話すようになった。
話せるようになったのは国の関連なんです。
英語で話すようになった。
英語なのに、英語とかしてる。
べきではないけれども、どういう。
でも、すごいうまいじゃん。全然普通の英語っていう感じ。
ルイシさん一番好きなのはやっぱりスペイン語でしょ。
スペイン語でその次は英語。
英語。
リキー、あなたはアメリカ人の一般的に、集まって、ラティノの集まったら、冗談とか楽しい話があるじゃない。
わいわい。
でも、アメリカ人は、討論するじゃない。
中国では。
あ、そういう事でしょ。
ちょっと少し証拠を覧めてる。
私は中国の…
そうね、ヤスコさん、中国の…
そっか、わかんない。
ヤスコさん、同じだと思って。
いらっしゃらなくなっちゃったから、やめちゃったのよ。
そうなんですよ。
アメリカは好きってこと。
アメリカは。
リベート?
リベートみたいな。
日本はあんまりやらないから。
でも、そもそもこのリベートだ。
私、アメリカ人ではないから、でも見ると、大喧嘩ですけどもね。
実際にこのディスカッション、リベートだ。
年齢とグループによって違うかな。
アメリカ人も持ってきますね。
最近もね、それ頼んだら、最近断られた。
え?なんで?
なんかね、人によって、この人は英語の人とか、この人とはフランス語とかって。
人はね、人と語学は一緒になってて、めめはいつも日本語だったから、今も英語なんてダメだって。
だけど、急に私はなんか英語で言うと、気が付くんないのよ。
え?そう?
全然英語でパッて答えてくる。
ああ、そうだよね。今。
行きましょう。